what's it like making this murder
mystery was a lot of fun what's fun you
know it's uh it's a fun you know murder
mysteries have been done forever so you
have to have a fun and fresh idea of how
to approach it and I think Ryan did that
very well both in the writing the
casting and yet it's a murder mystery
yeah you have Captain America and James
Bond in this movie also what was that
like I like to refer to them as actually
actors Daniel Craig and Chris Evans in
the movies we all listened it was a it
was not a movie where we were all
separated the room that we all hung out
in all day every day was no bigger sort
of than this little corner it was it was
in the basement of this house we were
shooting in and it was the only road we
could be in so you were there together
all the time all day you know that
people share a lot of war stories a lot
of show business stories all right now
it looked like Michael Myers was dead
we're good but we always know somehow he
is always reincarnated is this it was
that the end or with or is there a
chance he could come back
do you want them to come back of course
I do
do you you want admit you want them to
watch Laurie and Michael mm-hmm it will
be the sort of love story of my life I
mean besides my own actual love story
it's better than the Lori Michaels story
[Music]